[Musique]
donc atteint
c'est une scène quotidienne à la havane
des files d'attentes désorganisé devant
des supérettes de l'attention de la
fatigue ce que se disputent ces cubains
de quoi manger
premier arrivé premier servi lille
connaît sa pire crise économique depuis
30 ans des saucisses
à l'embargo américain se sont ajoutés la
pandémie et une réforme monétaire peu
opportune le peso s'effondrent les
pénurie s'aggrave les gens ont faim ils
ont faim à cuba
le jour se lève à peine sur la vieille
havane pour jesús batista enseignant à
la retraite la quête de nourriture est
devenue un travail à plein temps
bonjour qu'est ce qui est vendu ici
de l'huile mais il paraît qu'il n'y en
aura pas pour tout le monde
cuba importe 80% de ses besoins la crise
de kobe 19 a paralysé l'île les magasins
d'état sont vides
ils disent qu'il n'y a que 100 bidons
d'huile il y en aura pas pour tout le
monde vous avez vu la foule tous les
jours c'est pire je fais la queue avec
cette incertitude est ce que je veux
voir quelque chose ou pas est-ce que ça
va marcher cette fois ou pas
au bout de trois heures cette
responsable masque jaune annonce qu'il
n'y a que 60 bouteilles d'huile à bas
prix sur les 100 premiers
désillusion pour le retraité et ses
compagnons d'infortuné
dans la file j'ai rien eu
et quand est ce que vous êtes arrivé
c'est là que depuis hier soir
lui est payé pour faire la queue à la
place des autres un nouveau petit métier
au pays de la débrouille
les plus chanceux repartent avec leur
huile comme un trésor presos lui rentrer
bredouille dans son modeste immeuble le
moral en berne
comme une grande partie des cubains
entre coupures d'électricité et
inflation galopante plus 70%
officiellement l'année dernière
l'ambiance est morose à la havane
la capitale n'est plus que l'ombre
d'elle même c'est plus célèbre emblème
sont même menacés
comme ces vieilles voitures américaines
georget est très fier de sa chevrolet 56
elle appartient à sa famille depuis
plusieurs générations
mais il ne sait pas s'il pourra la
conserver longtemps
avant la pandémie on se débrouillait
pour trouver les pièces détachées mais
là le pays est isolé on importe plus
rien les pièces sont très cher en plus
le tourisme a chuté n'y a plus d'argent
qui rentre cette voiture c'est ma vie et
celle de ma famille
sur le bord de la route les cubains ne
prête plus attention aux slogans
socialiste qui vante les idéaux de la
révolution de 1959
[Applaudissements]
lorsqu'il fait ses courses au marché où
les prix s'envolent
cet informaticien de 38 ans ose exprimer
le sentiment de nombreux enfants et
petits enfants de la révolution
qu'on ne peut plus parler d'égalité
sociale quand on voit le gouvernement
crée de l'inégalité c'est un conte c'est
du passé notre génération a perdu les
illusions qu'avait nos parents on n'a
pas la même expérience nous notre seule
préoccupation c'est la nourriture la
nourriture
sous pression le gouvernement pourrait
accélérer les réformes économiques
depuis 2021 les petites entreprises
privées sont autorisés dans presque tous
les secteurs pour ce jeune patron c'est
le moyen de sortir cuba de la crise avec
les vingt employés de sa pme
d'électricité ils travaillent sur les
chantiers de lave
les jeunes recherchent un travail qui
les motive
la meilleure manière de les attirer
c'est de leur donner cette possibilité
de travailler librement d'avoir
l'initiative
dans de nombreux cas les emplois du
privé sont beaucoup plus attractifs que
ceux du secteur public
dans l'île socialiste l'entrepreneuriat
se développe à la faveur de la crise